[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم انا ميسون عزام واحييكم
وهذا اللقاء الخاص مع الرئيس الفلسطيني
المتحده اللهجه كانت قاسيه بعد الشيء قويه
جدا ذكرت بعض النقاط سامر على النقطه
الاولى وهي تتعلق بالاتفاقيات لعام 93
التي قلت بانها لم تعد قائمه على الارض هل
توفت
يعني بالنسبه لنا الاتفاقيات مع اسرائيل
مفروض انها لا زالت قائد ونحن لا يمكن ان
نتراجع او نتخلى عن الاتفاقيه الا انهم
بتصرفاتهم منذ فتره من الزمن منذ اكثر من
ست سبع سنوات وهم ينقضون كل ما تم الاتفاق
عليه
وبالتالي يعني يعملون عكس كل هذه
الاتفاقيات امام هذا الوضع لا نملك ان
نبقى على التمسك والالتزام بهذه
الاتفاقيات ولذلك نحن في اي لحظه ممكن ان
همم نخله طرفنا منها
ذكرت قرار 181 قرار التقسيم يعني بدنا
نرجع على عكا وعلى الناصره وذكرت 194
وطالبت بتنفيذ هذا القرار والا معاقبه
اسرائيل
وايضا تعليق عضويتها اذا لم ينفذ هذا
يعتبر بديل الاتفاقيه اوصله ليس كذلك
وعن مجلس الامن وعن حقوق الانسان
جعلتني اعود الى المطالبه بهذه القرارات
يعني عندما نعرف انه صدر بحق الشعب بحق
القضيه الفلسطينيه
754 قرار من الجمعيه العامه لم ينفذ قرار
واحد
و94 قرار من مجلس الامن لم ينفذ قرار واحد
ومثلها من حقوق الانسان لم ينفذ قرار واحد
فانا الحقيقه اخترت القرار 181 والقرار
104 164 القرار 180 يتكلم عن التقسيم
والتقسيم لم ينفذ المهم هناك نقطه هامه
جدا وهي ان اسرائيل عندما طلبت ان تكون
عضوا في الامم المتحده
اشتريت عليها في ذلك الوقت ان تقبل وتنفذ
القرار 184
والا لن تكون عضو في الامم كان في ذلك
الوقت مش غريب هو وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي
وتعهد خطيا للامم المتحده انني سالتزم
بهذين القرارين او وتطبيقهما وبناء عليه
قبلت اسرائيل في الامم المتحده والى الان
لم ينفذ هذان القرار الان انا بدي تنفيذ
هذه القرارات
المتحده بانه يضعها على جدول اعماله من
اجل تطبيق هذين القرارين بمعنى اولا
تطبيقهم فيما يتعلق بحقنا في فلسطين فيما
يتعلق بحق اللاجئين وفيما يتعلق بعضويه
اسرائيل وهي
ادويه غير قانونيه الان اسرائيل منذ دخلت
الامم المتحده الى الان ليست عضوا رسميا
وليست عضوا قانونيه بناء على
هذين القرنين الذين
[موسيقى]
ولكن عندما قدمت فخامه الرئيس هذا الطلب
قدمت على اساس ورقه تريد ان ترفعها الان
في هذه الفتره الحساسه او لا لانه فعلا
يقوم الامين العام للامم المتحده بواجبه
في همم الجمعيه العامه ونحن من جانبنا
سنتقدم للجمعيه العامه بطلب تنفيذهما يعني
لن نتركها ايضا للامين العام وانما نحن
اعضاء مراقبين ومن حقنا انه يقدم طلب ان
يقدم طلب تنفيذ هذين القرنين مش بس مجرد
انه
ده نحكي حكي لا بدي نطلب تنفيذهم هل انت
متفائل لا لا طبعا انا مش متفائل سبب
اللي ضربنا على مدى 70 سنه 74 سنه مش راح
ينصفنا هذه الايام الشيء الاخر وبصراحه
الذي يقف حجر عثره في طريق تنفيذ القرارات
وبالذات قرارات همم مجلس الامن هي امريكا
امريكا يعني هي السند الاساس السنه دي
الوحيد الان لاسرائيل في
رفضها لكلها عدم الالتزام بهذه القرارات
يعني بدي اضل يعني طالب امريكي
مع الامريكان نتحدث بهذه القضايا لعل وعسى
ياتي وقت
يتغير الموقف الامريكي يتغير اقوم ان شاء
الله عند ذلك نحن
ولكن الان يتم التعامل معها على اساس دوله
احتلال هذا من خلال الخطاب خبرنا شو طبيعه
التعاطي الان كيف يختلف
للمحكمه
الدوليه
هل هو احتلال
الاستيطاليه هل هو احتلال كل ينادي ام هو
تمييز عن سوريا
وهذا القلب عندما قدمناه مؤخرا يعني والان
بطريقه التصويت عليه على خلال ايام ان شاء
الله على الاقل نحصل على قرار من
المحكمه صحيح قرارات المحكمه اييه
استشاريه وليست الزاميه لكن اعتقد ان دول
كثير من دول العالم
ستقف عند هذا القرار اي قرار تغدوه وانا
اتوقع ان تقول انه هذا ابطال التايد
ستعامل مع اسرائيل على هذا الاساس وهذا
اللي بهم يعني انه الراي العام الدولي
يتغير بهمني ان الروايه الفلسطينيه هي
التي تسود حتى يومنا هذا الروايه
الصهيونيه هي السائده في كل في القضيه
الفلسطينيه نحنا الان عم نحاول بكل
وسائلنا من خلال الاقناع الناس من خلال
البحث في التاريخ ومن خلال الحديث
لك احنا بدات الامور تتطور وبالذات في
المجتمع الامريكي يعني الان في المجتمع
الامريكي هناك تغييرات جيده اقول كبيره
هائله لكن هذه التغيرات لتفهم الروايه
الفلسطينيه عندما يفهم الروايه يعني يفهم
ان احنا ظلمنا واحنا طهنا ونحن لم نخرج
برغبتنا من بلادنا ونحن ذبحنا ونحن همم
بحريه عدد كبير 500 قريه من قرانه
حتى اجبرنا ان نرحل هذه واحده من الاشياء
وغيرها من القضايا التي يعني
تعارض او تناقض
الروايه الصهيونيه
الغربيه
الدول اوروبا
الصهيونيه كما تقول سببها الضعف من الجانب
الفلسطيني
احنا مغيبين كنا يعني عندما بدا يعني
عندما جاء الى فلسطين
وزاره فلسطين في سنه 1900
وشاف انه في فلسطين في ناس في عالم
قال علينا ان نعمل على محو الفلسطينيين من
فلسطين لتصبح فلسطين
في اسرائيل
في كثير من شعوب العالم
لهذا التقريب هو سبب
غياب روايتنا الفلسطينيه
والداعي لان نعمل كل ما نستطيع من اجل
تثبيت الروايه الفلسطينيه
بتخاف على حياتها مهدده
يقتلوني يعني حتى فلسطين مش بعيد عن القتل
سواء من قبل الاسرائيليه وغيرهم يعني
فلسطين التاريخيه
نحن سبعه مليون فلسطين في فلسطين تاريخيه
الذي
شعره
في فلسطين
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم مجددا لازلنا وهذا
اللقاء الحصري مع الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس فخامه الرئيس اعود اليك للحديث عن
نقطه ذكرتها في الجزء الاول قلت انه نحن
ملتزمين بالاتفاقات التي وقعناها ولكن
روحت اكثر من مره بحل السلطه
وايضا بوقف التنسيق
اهل السلطه
الفلسطينيه موجوده
لا احد يستطيع اللجوء الاحتلال يعمل اي
اجراءات من اجل ان احد سلطه اما السلطه
باقيه ولم تنتهي
في يوم من الايام
[موسيقى]
والسلطه جاءت من رحم هذا الاتفاق وبالتالي
اذا لم ينفذ
تثبيت وجود الشعب الفلسطيني
للوصول الى دوله بدون احتلال احنا الان
بصراحه في فلسطين دوله كامله
دوله كامله
العناصر فيها كل شيء بس نخلص من الاحتلال
الرئيسيه التي لا تطبق حتى الان وبالتالي
ما هي الخيران
نحاول الاول مع العالم
وطبعا اخواننا معنا اخواننا العرب معنا
لكن نحن نحكي مع العالم العالم لنقنعه
بالروايه الفلسطينيه ليفهم انه في شعب
فلسطيني ليفهم ان هذا الشعب له حقوق له
حقوق وان هو موجود منذ القدم
للسلطه الفلسطينيه
انه محاربه الارهاب اينما كان
اين مكان
يكون في نقطه مهمه يمكن ما حد بعرفها نحن
عاقدين اتفاقيات
لمحاربه الارهاب والعنف مع 85 دوله في
العالم على راسه مين الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا
بالاتفاق الامني مساء الغي التزامي
بالاتفاق الامريكي اذا استمرت اسرائيل
تضرب بعض الحائط كل
القضايا كل الامور الانسانيه والسياسيه
اللي بيننا وبينه
البعض يطالب فيه ويقول انه ضد المصلحه
الفلسطينيه البعد الاخر يقول انه لا هذا
الفلسطيني لا يستطيع ان يتنفس الا من خلال
هذا التنسيق
وشعبنا موجود
المقاومه الشعبيه السلميه التي لا تقل عن
السلاح الان المقاومه الشعبيه في كل مكان
في كل مكان
ولها تفعيل لها اثارها ولها
نتائج التي
يلمسها الاسرائيلي
بدات تظهر بالفتره الاخيره وكان في توسع
لها يقال انه العمليات اكثر من نسبه
العمليات اللي كانت ب 2015
والمقاومه السلميه
فالحديث عن هذه النقطه بتهمني كثير لانه
اعتقد ربما يرجك على الاقل في المحافل
الدوليه هل تحرجه
بس انا بالنسبه للمقاومه العسكريه
هلا انا ممكن تغير رايك
اهلا وسهلا بالمقاومه العسكريه المسلحه
الكفاح المسلح الى
88 من 88
النادي الدولي
اياكم
توصلوا الشعب الفلسطيني بان يفقد صبره
قوى الامن في فلسطين لماذا لا تمنع
الاسرائيليين من الدخول وقد فعلتها
بالخليل
انا لا اريد ان اوصل الامور الى حد
الاستخدام المسلحه
51 مدحات وهلا بدو بعضهم يحكي هلا في فيلم
الان يذاع عندنا وهو في اليهودي عملوا
اسرائيلي اسمه طنطوره عن مذبحه واحده من
المذابح التي ارتكبت في عام 48
اللي ارتكبها الشباب
[موسيقى]
يعني بعد معه بقول له بدي دوله فلسطينيه
مستقله عاصمتها القدس على حدود 67
المجتمع الدولي وهو 67 وهذا بتنازلات
كثيره
67 طيب اقبلنا احنا بنقول مثلا
27 الي بيعطينا 22% فلسطين
طيب انا قاعد في بلدي بدي احكي مثل ما قلت
لك احنا الان
وصفوه بالازدواجيه في التعاطي مع مصطلح
التطبيع انه دول ااه يتم انتقادها ودول هل
في تطبيق حلو وتطبيع بشعه
الذي التي عقدت في عام 2002
والتي قدم في ذلك الوقت
الله يرحمه الملك عبد الله
مشروعه اللي اسمه المبادره العربيه
المبادره العربيه للسلام تقول بالحرف
الواحد
احنا مع التطبيع شرط ان يبدا بفلسطين يعني
ياخد الفلسطيني
لكن
ايش بتسوي اكثر من هيك
من خلال
اللقاء
انا موجود تحت الاحتلال
سياسيه ممكن ولكن
تقديم العزاء هل هذا من ضمن
الاردن
القمه هي قمه عربيه صينيه
يعني هي
مغيره او مكرره من اجل
العلاقات العربيه الصينيه وهي لاول مره
بتحصل طبعا انا ساقابل الرئيس الصيني لانه
فيه علاقات تاريخيه
بيننا وبين الصين 63 مش 64
احنا جاهزين لان السمع وجاهزين لان ندلي
براينا بموقفنا
فيما يتعلق باي شيء نطرح على جدول الاعمال
العلاقات الصينيه العربيه
بيننا وبيننا صاحب الجلاله الملك سلمان
وصاحب السمو ولي العهد
سؤال اخير وباختصار في ما يتعلق بالعلاقه
مع النظام السوري وخاصه دخول حماس على
الخط الان مع النظام
نفسها تعرف شو صار بينهم حماده لكن نحن
ايضا علاقتنا مش سيئه حلقتنا منيحه مع
النظام السوري
لم تتغير ولم تتبدل
وكفرتنا موجوده اتصالات قائمه ووفود
وقيادات تذهب الى الى سوريه
شيء طبيعي
[موسيقى]